olivier faur le premier secrétaire d'un
parti est sens dessus dessous le parti
socialiste est l'invité d'auditions
publiques votre nouveau rendez vous donc
du lundi sur les chaînes parlementaires
avec la fp avec le figaro bonsoir livier
fort et merci donc d'être avec nous ce
soir avec moi pour commencer la première
séquence stéphanie le rouge de la fp et
yves thréard du figaro bonsoir soit dans
un instant un député la république en
marche ancien socialiste et un sénateur
les républicains seront là une
confrontation mystère et puis dans la
dernière partie de l'émission
il y aura un organe mancini et ludovic
faut d'abord olivier fort bien sûr la
catastrophe dans dans l'eau de plus de
dix morts dans les inondations leur bien
sûr est encore au secours et bien sûr à
la solidarité nationale à voir également
le conte s'inquiète enfin pour ce qui va
arriver dans les heures qui viennent
notamment dans l'hérault quel est ce
soir votre votre message
et puis également peut-être les
premières interrogations avec cette
nouvelle catastrophe climatique dans le
premier message c'est d'abord un message
à la fois de solidarité et de
condoléances par rapport à ces familles
qui ont perdu leurs proches dans un
événement qui est effectivement emporté
vous le dites vous même
une dizaine de personnes au moment où
nous parlons mais peut-être ce bilan est
il appelé à s'alourdir
je veux saluer aussi des services
publics qui sont aujourd'hui en action
parce que on a toujours cette facilité
de considérer qu'ils ne servent à rien
toujours fustigé ses fonctionnaires mais
quand ils sont là et qui sont les
premiers secours on est heureux de les
trouver et donc je veux leur rendre
hommage
dans leurs actions et leur mobilisation
les blagues l'hommage et de la
constatation qui était terrible on voir
un que ces épisodes sont de plus en plus
fréquent alors les scientifiques sont
pas tous d'accord est ce que c'est
imputables au réchauffement climatique
ou pas mais s'il n'y a pas moyen de
davantage bien prévenir ce genre de
drame
jean luc mélenchon dit saïd il faudrait
même quasiment un ministère du salut
public écologique votre avis je ne sais
pas si ça mine salut salut public mais
en tout cas ils seraient 200
gouvernement
gouvernementale public ce serait ça
rappelle d'autre part notre histoire sur
le boulevard sur de salut public
moi ce que je crois c'est que
effectivement il est temps sur cette
question qui est la question climatique
de mettre le paquet et que les
gouvernements qui sont succédé ont tous
fait un pari qui est celui du progrès
jean luc mélenchon y compris quand il
était ministre et qui ont toujours parié
sur le fait qu' un jour nous serions en
mesure finalement de te contredire ce
qui paraissait déjà l'évidence pour le
giec pour ce groupe de chercheurs qui
travaillent sur le climat depuis très
longtemps et donc a rendu son rapport
mais qu'elle ait rendu ses rapports ça
fait de très nombreuses années qu'ils
rendent des rapports et qu'ils ont le
sentiment parfois de prêcher c'est le
cas de le dire dans le désert et donc il
y avait été aujourd'hui pour la
puissance publique pour les gouvernants
pour les politiques de ne pas continuer
à procrastiner somo qui sert simplement
à dire que on remet toujours au
lendemain ce qu'on devrait faire le jour
même et c'est tout le problème
aujourd'hui sur laquelle on parlait pas
vers le monde réagit vous mais vous avez
tort de vous avez tort de dire ça nous
avons quelques années fait un virage
cette question là qu est un virage
extrêmement important nous avons même
sur notre propre logo le mot social
écologie et n'êtes pas sans ignorer que
dans le quinquennat précédent
la coop 21 à la transition énergétique
la convergence sur les prix les tarifs
des carburants pour donner un signal sur
la question donc du diesel tous ces
éléments là où j'ai mis dans deux dans
la corbeille collective et vous voyez
bien aussi qu'aujourd'hui les
collectivités locales qui sont dirigées
par la gauche photo des efforts qui sont
sans comparaison notamment je pense par
exemple à paris à nantes à rennes à
dijon toutes ces villes où aujourd'hui
la question de mental est une priorité
totale absolue stéphanie en lien avec
les inondations et à la question de
l'artificialisation des sols
on sait que c'est un
voilà le ps par exemple est favorable
aux europa city est un projet qui va
artificialisés énormément est ce qu'il
n'ya pas une contradiction entre
justement ces impératifs écologiques et
puis des habitus des habitudes de 2,2
d'élus locaux qui ont l'habitude le
promouvoir l'activité l'emploi etc via
ses projets mais je partage votre avis
je pense qu'il ya aujourd'hui matière à
interrogation sur tous ces grands
projets d'infrastructure qui peuvent
effectivement conduire à une
artificialisation des terres et dans la
monde comme dans le département de
l'aude qui t'as un département rural et
où tout ça n'est pas anticipé forcément
est magnifique ça peut produire les
catastrophes qui sont dramatiques vous
nous dites que ce genre de catastrophes
nous rappelle l'utilité bien sûr des
services publics mais là il ya météo
france qui est un petit peu interrogé
puisque peut-être que les alertes alerte
rouge n'a pas été donnée convenablement
au bon moment est ce que là il faut
s'interroger sur les mises en garde
adressées les populations est ce qu'il
peut et est-ce qu'il ya eu des
manquements des défaillances il faut se
poser la question
il faut toujours se mettre dans l'idée
qu'il faut évaluer après une catastrophe
quelle qu'elle soit quelques
parlementaires par exemple je ne sais
pas si tu as une enquête parlementaire
on va pourquoi pas demain sur mais
j'attendais on pourrait la demande et et
le supposerait qui en accordant de
l'assemblée pour ce soit une commission
qui soit une commission la rage qui
réunissent toute sensibilité parce que
cette question-là ya c'est pas une
affaire d'ordre clivages politiques
entre nous en tout cas je l'espère mais
il ya la nécessité de vérifier
effectivement ce qui s'est passé est ce
qu'on pouvait prévenir ce qu'on pouvait
anticiper est ce qu'il ya eu faute
et dans le cas d'un associé là de la
part de qui de quoi l'acteur est donc
alors chercher en tirer les
enseignements pour l'avenir le
remaniement du coup attendra même si
apparemment la liste des ministres je ne
suis pas sûr que ce soit liées à cette
catastrophe bien sûr même si je
comprends que ce soit un bon motif pour
le repousser d'une journée
vous pensez que c'est vrai c'est un
stade qui explique qu'on repousse d'une
journée allez pour vous c'est un
prétexte là je n'en sais rien je vois
juste
j'ai ce week-end était en contact avec
un président de département qui a été
socialiste qui a été interrogé pour sa
volonté de rentrer au gouvernement
il a refusé non non pas de lui un autre
un autre mais un autre aura second
alors qu'ils étaient sollicités j'ai pas
faire de name dropping comme on est
maintenant à bas les ici les unions je
ne dirai rien enfin en tout cas ce que
je veux dire par là c'est pas leur
position honteuse ans il a reçu vous
pouvez donner son nom je vois bien que
il ya une recherche permanente d'aller
chercher celui ou celle qui pourrait
finalement accepter
ils finiront bien par le trouver a
toujours des gens qui par ambition
personnelle sont prêts à rentrer dans un
gouvernement y compris quand ils n'en
partage pas forcément l'intégralité mais
ce que je vois c'est que c'est un
gouvernement qui a beaucoup de mal à se
constituer parce qu'il n'ya pas
finalement le banc de touche en ce
gouvernement est là où il ya un an
emmanuel macron il est extrêmement
séduisant pour nombre de français
aujourd'hui
il n'incarne plus la même chose et c'est
donc quand avant il y avait un
gouvernement qui qu'il fallait refaire
et tous accusés dans la hâte dans la
précipitation
pourquoi ne pas accepter ne pas
comprendre que l'on mette un peu de
temps pour constituer un gouvernement
appelé à durer qui soit solide avec les
bons les bonnes têtes
pourquoi pas mais enfin je ne suis pas
sûr que ce qui se prépare actuellement
son destin de cet entrelacs je vois que
y compris c'est un gouvernement qui a
usé ses ministres de manière très
prématuré dans la crème deux piliers du
gouvernement
nicolas hulot et gérard collomb qui
démissionne dans des conditions
rocambolesques qui ne prennent même pas
le chef du gouvernement ni le président
a rappelé les risques politiques et vous
actuellement
je ne sais pas s'il faut l'appeler crise
politique est en tout cas une crise du
maquereau nisme pourquoi ah parce que il
y a un an
le maquereau nice menait une objet
indéfini un espèce d'ovni politique mais
qui cherchait sa définition est donc
chacun pouvait finalement il voir
matière a intérêt à droite comme à
gauche
un an plus tard que se passe-t-il et
bien en tout cas je parle de mon côté
pour les gens de gauche qui se sont
endormis en pensant qu'il avait élu un
nouveau michel rocard se sont rendus
compte que le seul qui était fidèle à sa
propre pensée depuis un an ses droits si
l'ip le premier ministre qui aurait mené
peu ou prou la même politique avec alain
juppé ou françois fillon il devait être
un héros progressiste il est un néo
libérale il devait
être l'homme d'exemplarité il est
l'homme d'un clan il devait être celui
qui dégaine façon vous savez qu'on
cherche à draguer donc des futurs
ministres de gauche et là vous mettez
votre veto alors vous voyez pas
rééquilibrer ce gouvernement mais vous
avez résidera de ses bibliothèques de
veto à m on vous consulte apparemment il
arrive qu'on me consulte mais là en
l'occurrence face à nous on a consulté
on m'a prévenu que c'est le quelqu'un
avait été je vais appeler effectivement
pour le remercier de ce qui me semblait
être un acte à la fois normalement même
temps de courage dans la mesure où
aujourd'hui les pressions à l'ambition
sont telles que parfois il parvient à
nous ça fait beaucoup de l'entrée de
didier guillaume vous avez un message à
lui transmettre
mais disait guillaume a quitté parti
socialiste il a quitté notre social iste
au sénat il est parti au rds eux et je
crois que chacun a compris depuis
longtemps qu'il était complètement en
accord avec ce qui se fait au
gouvernement
en rappel la sgm inventé les quand même
le hollandisme pendant cinq ans sans
doute mais même sans aucun doute mais ce
que je vois c'est que et son évolution
personnelle l'a conduit depuis fort
longtemps
d'abord à quitter la vie politique puis
à y revenir sous une bannière qui n'est
pas celle du ps
alors c'était un week-end douloureux
pour vous puisque c'était un week-end de
scission avec des départs sur un 19 ans
sont partis comme à eva le départ de
terrain vous voulez
emmanuel maurel il ya quand même une
fracture à l'intérieur du parti
socialiste qui s'est manifesté avec des
gens qui seront plutôt attiré par le jeu
dirait le tropisme mélenchonistes
question ça va être difficile de réunir
ce parti socialiste aujourd'hui mais
d'abord vous me parlez la donne de
quelques départs on parle de l'ailé
gauche 6 et de l'agglo on parle en fait
dans des bars on a perdu quelques plumes
la réalité c'est que l'immense majorité
de ceux qui ont étaient les soutient
emmanuel maurel dans le congrès du parti
socialiste pour parler de cuisine et
bien sont restés ils étaient 7000 voix
au congrès ils nous annoncent qu'ils
vont partir peut-être à 500 faites vous
même la soustraction et vous comprendrez
que l'essentiel des forces
demain est élu vous raconter les
ministres c'est ce qui permettra de ne
pas les dénombrer et c'est ce qui sera
assez facile
donc vous n'êtes pas besoin photo tels
que peut un jardin la question la
question de fond c'est est ce qu'il ya
aujourd'hui des gens qui préfèrent
partir chez jean luc mélenchon s'il ya
des gens qui se sentent mieux chez jean
luc mélenchon qu'ils aillent chez jean
luc mélenchon ils veulent créer un parti
vous avez compris que c'était le faux
nez pour rentrer dans une liste aux
européennes avec jean luc mélenchon
moi je ne je ne suis pas là pour
caporaliser les uns et les autres s'il
ya des gens qui se pensent mieux loti
avec jean luc mélenchon c'est leur voix
500 jeudi mais il peut pour vous parce
que ça des toits un peu le parti
socialiste de ceux qui ne suivent pas
dans sa ligne qui est la vôtre
je ne dirais pas je ne faisais pas ces
mots là je ne pense pas qu'il faille
nettoyer et j'ai le plus profond respect
y compris pour ceux qui peuvent à un
moment donné faire des choix différents
des miens simplement ce que je dis c'est
que ce parti là il a vécu trop longtemps
avec des gens qui venaient se servir
mais qui ne le servez plus est donc
plutôt que d'avoir sans doute trop
longtemps vous ayez donc ils vont se
servir ailleurs sur les listes mélenchon
s'ils veulent s'allier ailleurs s'ils
veulent exporter leur mal-être ailleurs
qu'il le fasse que ça semblait
simplement
ce départ c'est que le ps a perdu sa
force d'attraction c'est à dire que
voilà le celui qui peut sembler l'avenir
de la gauche entre guillemets ou d'une
alternative sociale et écologique comme
il dit puisque tu veux pas parler de la
gauche c'est jean luc mélenchon et le ps
à brec'h cela si vous pouvez dire 60
aussi définitive avec le quand on a
aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui fut
l'assistant parlementaire de jean luc
mélenchon qui le rejoint et son ancien
complice de toujours qui était marie
noëlle lienemann donc on a plutôt la
reconstitution d'une ligue dissoute et
donc c'est ce qui l'a d'ailleurs venu
leur dire à marseille en disant qu'il y
avait une tellement manqué sa famille de
pensée de coeur intellectuelle et donc
il y à la recomposition de gens qui ont
toujours tout fait ensemble sous leur
vrai chemin de croix pour vous ce parti
socialiste la caisse qu'elle vit vous
allez lui imprimer à l'heure où
justement vos avis allemand du spd bien
subissent un revers électoral en bavière
moins dix points c'est quand même pas
mal où ils sont mal à l'aise d'ailleurs
dans la coalition gouvernementale
c'est difficile aujourd'hui de défendre
un socialisme qu'elle est c'est quoi
votre socialisme à vous mais qui seront
réservées raison de dire que la crise
que nous subissons aujourd'hui que nous
vivons est une crise
personne ne peut le nier et qu'elle
n'est pas uniquement nationale elle est
aussi européenne
de quoi bien tél elle vient du fait que
depuis trop longtemps
on ne sait plus identifié à un projet
qui soit un projet perçu par les
français
ils savent que nous ne sommes ni macro
ni mélenchon mais au fond il leur manque
ce que nous sommes vraiment et c'est la
raison pour laquelle dans laquelle sur
la question européenne par exemple
ce week end nous avons adopté un projet
qui le projet que nous porterons dans
l'élection européenne et qui lui est
très claire et qui dit ce que nous
voulons faire sur la question écologique
sur la question migratoire sur la
question économique sur la question
budgétaire pour toutes ces questions là
nous sommes à nouveau en situation
d'être audible parce que nous avons à
nouveau la clarté sur ce que l'on
souscrit en opposition et donc moi je
souhaite un parti sioniste qui soit pour
simplifier les choses vraiment à gauche
est vraiment réaliste alors c'est
vraiment à gauche parce que nous ne
pouvons pas les
et penser qu' il y à une confusion qui
s'organiserait au niveau européen entre
les uns et les autres parce que ça
laisserait la place demain une
alternative unique qui serait celle des
populistes et nationalistes ce que je ne
veux pas et parce que je n'ai pas la
même vision de l'europe que ce qui est
que défendent même le maquereau ou les
oraux libéraux qui portent autre chose
que ce que nous avons apporté les
familles qui vous souhaiteriez voir pour
tirer la liste du ps ya le nom de
ségolène royal qui est sorti récemment
valérie rabault elle défend la
candidature de eric andrieu qui est
assez inconnu des français qu'est ce que
vous pensez de ces deux candidatures la
france comme le chef de l'état vous
chercher inlassablement
mais non je ne cherche pas à simplement
je pense avait trouvé à trouver je pense
que il y aller post il ya aujourd'hui
des candidats possibles gilles femme ou
un homme
je ne vous dirais qu'à soir battant des
non-jeûneurs nous donner les noms ce
n'est pas le jeu mais simplement que
haut dé plus depuis trop longtemps nous
avons pris l'habitude de commencer
toujours par la question de
l'incarnation alors que pour moi la
question essentielle c'est d'abord le
messager vous savez trés je veux vivre
ensemble votre projet le projet est
adopté
mais pour l'instant vous aurez noté
qu'on en a peu parlé mais moi je
préférais d'abord commencé par parler de
ce que nous voulons faire au niveau
européen
dire par exemple que plus jamais nous
voulons signer d'accords commerciaux qui
ont qui privilégie le libre échange sur
le juste échange qui n'est pas logique
de vous rapporter aujourd'hui du lait de
l'autre bout du monde quand nous sommes
ici sédentaires que c'est pas logique de
traiter que le mercosur pour pouvoir
importer de la viande que nous sommes
des centaines xm intérêt ici qu'il n'est
pas logique de faire venir de l'énergie
provenant du gaz de schiste avec le
canada parce que nous n'avons nous avons
ici au contraire un moratoire sur ces
énergies là voilà des choses que je
serai dans le port sera alors dressé le
portrait idéal c'est un homme une femme
qui porte ses convictions l'avaient rêvé
je suis en train de discuter ce que vous
aurez compris que ma volonté n'est pas à
chaque fois d'imposer mais de chercher à
faire avancer ensemble des gens qui
allaient des appris à travailler
ensemble est l'un des grands problèmes
de ce parti
c'est d'avoir été avec des écuries qui
s'affrontaient en permanence et qui
n'avait plus le goût du travail en
commun se colle et donc j'essaye de
restaurer sur les rails entre certaines
difficiles c'est compliqué parce que il
ya des égos il y aller il y a aussi des
égoïsmes il y a aussi des ambitions
il ya aussi des frustrations il ya aussi
des divergences toujours puisque vous
devez définir votre programme européen
par exemple vous êtes contre les accords
commerciaux un jean bleu pas compte du
libéralisme président parisien soumettre
h à l'accord un interdit par exemple
écologie évidemment que là vous avez
vous avez fermé la porte à pierre
moscovici puisqu'il défend ses organes
en position que femme l'actrice mila
était laquelle ils obligent l'état qui
détient pour qu'il apporte aux racines
revient ou cas à la question n'est pas
là la question ce n'est pas de savoir si
on fait plaisir à telle ou telle la
question c'est de savoir si nous pouvons
nous retrouver d'abord nous même si nous
pouvons à nouveau être audible sur un
message de fond reviendra t sont un
message qu'il porte et je n'ai jamais
perdu contact avec lyon continuait à
continuer à discuter y compris après son
interview au monde c'est ça la question
que vous posez et donc j'ai le sentiment
qu'il a été socialiste
nous verrons bien ce qu'il entend faire
mais moi ce que je dis c'est qu'il ne
s'agit pas aujourd'hui de faire plaisir
à tel ou tel mais de nous retrouver
d'abord en nous mêmes quel est le
message que nous voulons porter avec
lequel nous avions un accord nous même
quand je ne sais pas si les uns et les
autres seront d'accord sur l'idée que
désormais sur les critères de
convergence sur le déficit on doive ou
pas moi c'est en tout cas ce que je
porte
exclure la question de dépenses qui
porte sur la transition énergétique
pourquoi je dis ça parce que tout
simplement je sais très bien que si on
ne le fait pas cette question les
réserves énergétiques sera toujours la
cinquième roue du carrosse et que nous
n'irons jamais assez vite à un moment où
ce qui se passe peut être irréversibles
pour la planète et c'est la raison pour
laquelle il faut avancer maintenant
alors je suppose des ruptures quand là
aussi pourquoi le nom de cet encan 17
novembre 17 nope en faudrait encore un
peu patient un merci merci à tous les
deux une question est-ce que selon vous
le parti socialiste peut parler à jean
luc mélenchon c'est ce que demande la
lune et partant du week end
est ce que vous estimez qu'on ne peut
pas par les agents
mais je parle avec jean luc mélenchon
chaque semaine à l'assemblée c'est pas
simplement quand mais je lui parle parce
que à la belote pas seulement à la
buvette est on est enfin j'ai proposé il
ya quelques semaines des combats comme
moi je ne suis pas un rôle artifices de
d'alliance d'appareils qu'ils finiraient
par gommer les divergences et les
différences sur la question européenne
elles sont fondamentales jean luc
mélenchon est un oui noro sceptique je
suis sam européen convaincu je pense
qu'on ne peut pas résoudre la question
du climat ou la question migratoire vous
des sans passer par le niveau discrétion
qu'elle aura du sujet de fond et ensuite
il ya des sujets de fond sur lequel nous
pourrons nous retrouver à sur les
questions démocratiques nous sommes
retrouvés au moment de la sphère benalla
s'il ya des questions sur les terres sur
un projet de gouvernement mais on en
n'est pas là moi je loge non pas des cas
des quatre ans d'amour je chercherai
vous pouvez pas refaire à ce qu'il y ait
des preuves c'est à nouveau possible
c'est-à-dire aux sceptiques mais je
crois avoir compris qu'il était plus
gros sceptiques il était en fait vous
êtes vous avez défendre la même europe
que celle de manuel macro je reconnais
là votre esprit de provocation mais il
n'est pas question pour moi de dire que
je ne suis pas sûr les l'europe mais
elle m'a quand on va pouvoir poursuivre
sur ce thème va pas tout de suite
puisque maintenant nous avons donc nos
deux parlementaires qui vont faire leur
entrée sur ce plateau
merci à tous merci merci
[Musique]
voilà ils font le don que leur entrée
bonsoir messieurs olivier ferrand vous
avez été député socialiste vous êtes
aujourd'hui député la république en
marche de l'isère à vos côtés philippe
dallier sénateur les républicains de
seine saint denis en parlait de l'europe
à l'instant olivier ferrand et c'est un
sujet sur lequel vous voulez interpellé
notre invité avec qui vous êtes resté en
excellents termes bien sûr bonsoir
olivier faure c'est vrai que nous avons
partagé les mêmes bancs à l'assemblée
nationale et au delà des bancs
d'ailleurs nous partageons des valeurs
progressistes humaniste et profondément
européiste et quand on parle d'europe
nous partageons aussi l'idée qu'il faut
une europe plus sociale sous entendu
parler de la nécessité pour l'europe de
s'investir davantage sur la transition
écologique de la même façon on critique
souvent l'europe qu'on taxe de souffrir
d'un déficit démocratique et être trop
loin des citoyens et là nous allons
avoir une campagne électorale
fondamental parce que nous avons la
montée des populismes européen à la
hongroise ou à l'italienne de salvini et
puis nous avons une bonne partie de
l'opinion publique française j'en suis
convaincu qu'ils croient en l'europe et
qui aime l'europe et cet électorat là il
va nous falloir le mobiliser je pense
qu'il faut que nous soyons capables
d'innover en marche et nous avons fait
du porte-à-porte j'ai fait moi-même à
grenoble avec la grande marche en europe
s'il suit de très près les ateliers qui
ont été lancées par le parti socialiste
et beaucoup de propositions d'ailleurs
je les ai trouvés à titre personnel on l
avait lancé un appel non je ne danse pas
la pâleur parti socialiste que je veux
dire c'est que fort de ces constats je
me dis que nous devrions être capables
d'avoir une campagne électorale
européenne sur le fond sur les idées et
s'il doit y avoir des clivages
ils doivent être avant tout entre les
europhobes et les européistes convaincu
et qu'ensuite nous fassions valoir
évidemment nos différences car elles
sont réelles et nous allons sans doute
en parler mais je souhaite que nous
ayons une campagne pour l'europe
davantage une campagne contre telle ou
telle politique menée par tel ou tel
responsable politique est-ce que vous
êtes prêts c'est ma question
mais chez roland c c'est le fonds de
donateurs notre désaccord
je ne crois pas à cette alliance des
progressistes qui finalement reviendrait
à dire que si nous voulons changer
d'europe il faut passer demain
par les fourches caudines des populistes
et un final des nationalistes parce que
c'est exactement ce que vous produisez
vous valorisez en permanence est ce la
raison pour laquelle je dis que emmanuel
macron il même devenu un agent électoral
de ces nationalistes ils se sont choisis
les uns les autres
or ban salvini le pen ont choisi comme
épouvantail emmanuel macron emmanuel
macron réciproquement il a choisi comme
épouvantail l'élan et donc si je suis
poli je laisse ligne réalisée mais la
même façon qu'il s'est choisie pendant
un an
jean luc mélenchon comme épouvantail
pour pouvoir faire passer un sale nombre
de textes fins avec le soutien de la
droite sur le budget sur la question de
l'asile et de l'immigration sur d'autres
questions comme la loi les lois pénicaud
sur le travail il a cherché des alliés à
droite en se choisissant comme
épouvantail celui qui à gauche je vais
effrayer maintenant le voilà qui se
choisit un autre adversaire qui est
marine le pen salvini roban possible de
laisser penser que entre lui et le chaos
il n'y a rien moi je pense que c'est
exactement ce qui produit le chaos si
vous laisser penser qu' il n'ya pas
d'alternance possible y compris en
dessous des gens qui sont effectivement
pro-européen je suis pro européens comme
vous mais je ne veux pas la même europe
que vous et c'est donc pour cette raison
là que dit lors d'un débat ils de faire
une opposé mais considérées d'un concert
à nous laisser d'autres considèrent que
devant la loi ratage donc forcément le
même camp considéré que viktor orban ne
puisse être un épouvantail me semble
être une négation totale de l'urgence
devant laquelle nous sommes aujourd'hui
considérer que salvini puisse être un
épouvantail politique me semble être
véritablement en dessous pardon de le
dire des enjeux quand on est encore
salvini hier qui parle d'un couvre-feu
ethnique pour les épiceries après 21h
qu'ils seraient tenus par des personnes
qui ne fréquentent pas demander pardon
mais le président et faire le poids des
mots on ne peut pas considérer que
viktor orban ou monsieur salvini en
italie soit des épouvantails qu'on agit
très titre poli mais ses lacets
l'europe c'est la paix que nous
apportons ici alors de pouvoir est
dangereux mais pas non mais comment son
nom et commencez par faire croire aux
français que ce serait des épouvantails
non c'est pas des maisons d'arrêt non
c'est une catastrophe pour laura exe
tunisair pas trop pour l'heure c'est
peut-être une différence que nous avons
et ensuite c'est ensuite nous sommes ne
sommes pas choisi un épouvantail par
contre nous ne sommes pas non plus
choisi un allié de circonstance qui
pourrait être monsieur timberman ce qui
est prévu pour peut-être porter la voix
des socialistes à l'échelle européenne
si vraiment il ya une telle urgence
telle que vous la décrivez alors
combattez réellement ces politiques ce
que nous faisons faites en sorte que
quand la gouailleuse cherche avec 58
immigrants à venir accoster à marseille
ou à 7 ce soit possible faites en sorte
que le président la république ne dise
plus que ceux qui aujourd'hui font
métier de sauver des vies humaines sont
les complices des passeurs là
effectivement vous serez à la hauteur de
l'enjeu
j'étais très jeune j'étais député dans
une précédente loi sur l'immigration où
nous n'étions pas allés aussi loin pour
supprimer des hits solidarité et nous
l'avons fait ici regretter c'est que
c'est vraiment des sénateurs les
républicains moi j'avais une tête de
seine-saint-denis tu peux être sensible
au discours européen de parlementaires
qui à vos côtés et je suis rapidement
retrouvé tous les deux non écoutez je
suis relativement inquiet de la tactique
du président de la république parce
qu'on voit bien et c'est son intérêt
électoral qui cherche effectivement elle
se poser entre l'extrême droite et
l'extrême gauche il y à moi et rien
d'autre je pense que c'est effectivement
très grave et sur le sujet de l'europe
parce que laisser croire que par exemple
pour les républicains nous serions des
anti-européens excusez moi n'a peut-être
pas la même vision globale mais en tous
les cas je vais pas me définir
je pense que les français sont des
routes et qui pense effectivement
l'avenir de l'europe ne se définissent
pas comme ça la question effectivement
on est tous d'accord je pense ici pour
dire qu'on a deux ans durant laquelle
son c'est là qu'elle est sur des grands
sujets comme effectivement la sécurité
et l'immigration la politique économique
le soutien à l'investissement
il faudrait débattre sur le fond mais
non il s'agit également de national et
c'est là que vous posez alors qu'est ce
que vous avez à dire parce que c'est la
même on voit bien que pour main pour le
président de la république
si les républicains pourraient
disparaître si le ps pouvait disparaître
ça serait très bien pour lui avec le
risque effectivement qu'on se retrouve
peut-être avec un second tour avec un
choix entre marine le pen et mélenchon
voit des jours alors l'été vous ils
encouragent vous découragez store ou
emmanuel mal combat judiciaire pas lui
dire quoi je vais lui poser la question
du droit d'inventaire puisque le livre
parti sioniste recherche d'une politique
l'échec de 2017 a été retentissant
françois hollande n'a pas pu se
représenter et législatives ont été
calamiteuses pour le parti socialiste la
question est est ce que l'analyse des
raisons de cette défaite a été mené au
parti socialiste c'est ça la question
je vois françois hollande qui tente un
retour
c'est étonnant qui nous prédit une
dissolution peut-être après européenne
fasse assez surprenant après un échec
pareil que françois hollande repointe le
bout de son nez à la question c'est la
grande aventure vous l'avez fait vous
l'avez pas fait vous voulez la non mais
je vais répondre sérieusement c'est une
vraie question
et quand on a effectivement été
sanctionnés aussi lourdement
on va s'opposer à la fois la question de
savoir pourquoi qu'est-ce qui n'a pas
marché
qu'est ce qui n'a pas été compris et
compris pourquoi d'autres ont réussi
mieux que nous et donc ce que vous
n'avez pas fait les sarkozy cet
inventaire et qui vous coûte encore
parce que aujourd'hui encore on se
demande où est la droite
et bien moi je souhaite pouvoir le faire
dans les prochaines semaines et il y
aura un inventaire qui sera
effectivement produit depuis plusieurs
mois avec la fondation jean jaurès
nous travaillons nous auditionnons à ce
nombre de témoins d'acteurs cette
période là pour pouvoir tirer des
conclusion est tirée nous mêmes les
leçons de ce qui a été et une défaite
mémorable retentissante et qui a été
aussi un message qui nous a été adressé
à nous parler français et donc
effectivement il faut en tirer des
conclusions
il y avait une question sur françois
hollande 1 c'est lui l'avenir du ps ça
non la responsabilité de françois
hollande est quand même immense il n'a
pas eu le courage de se représenter
il a écrit ses mémoires ce que font tous
les présidents de la république qu'il
fasse le tour de france pour les les
vendre on le comprend mais on voit bien
il va au delà de cela et que son envie
de revenir pointe apparaît donc vous
pensez que françois hollande est une
possibilité pour le ps
à l'avenir mais j'entends enfin je vois
bien que dans la nébuleuse médiatique
politique et ses atouts bruissent autour
de françois hollande de des retours on a
dans ces histoires de gens qui parade
qui reviennent ça fait vendre beaucoup
de papier
la vérité c'est que comme dans les
échéances près passé il y aura une
élection primaire en 2011 et que ce sont
les militants les sympathisants du parti
socialiste qui décideront le moment venu
de qui sera notre candidat et donc
toutes ces spéculations qui agite le
monde politique n'ont pour moi aucun
intérêt on verra bien pourra se présente
il sera n'a pas été un pas dit enfin n'a
pas été déchu de ses droits civiques
mais c'est pour le reste attendons et on
est vraiment né mais c'est quand même
étonnant de voir cette vie politique ton
auto de la seule élection présidentielle
nous sommes à 4 ans l'élection
présidentielle on sait bien que même à
trois mois et à prédire qui sera le
président de la république est bien que
quatre ans avant on voudrait en
permanence sous peu à la question de
savoir qui m'écoutez ballet où cette
question-là islamabad savoir pour quoi
faire
et le débat est un mois mais il est très
présent là aujourd'hui on n'est pas dans
quatre ans il a aujourd'hui vous
embarrassent mais je ne sais pas s'il
doit embarrassé je dis simplement que
vous avez en permanence cette capacité à
aller spéculer aller scruter le moindre
mot de tel ou tel parce qu'il est
candidat futur potentiel à l'élection
présidentielle
moi ce que je vous dis c'est que ça
n'intéresse que nous et que les français
soient de nature alors olivier faur même
sur leur langue et les commentaires que
j'ai pu entendre sur le président qui
n'a pas de banc de touche et c'est on
spécule sur les questions de casting
mais c'est bien sûr la cornée est ce que
la vie politique elle est très claire à
une politique du gouvernement elle est
assumée elle est très claire et n'a pas
vocation à changer en étant toujours
déterminée mais éventuellement de
nouvelles personnes pour porter des
politiques mais j'entendais beaucoup de
commentaires aussi y compris venant de
vous bien sûr sur la question des
personnes en dix ans mais puisque la
personne n'a pas été trouvé
ces policiers que je regrette souliers
nord il ya c'est pas un politique de
four moi je vois je suis content que
vous le dis je vois bien que je ne suis
pas je vais pas courir après les chants
du remaniement pour moi si tu
épiphénomène je vais simplement que ce
que je trouve dramatique dans cette
circonstance pour ce remaniement c'est
que c'est le gouvernement lui même qui
annonce chaque jour que c'est le
lendemain et qui donne le sentiment
d'une incapacité à conclure c'est cette
impression qu elle donnait lui même
l'aurait dit dès le départ c'est dans
quinze jours c'était dans quinze jours
et peu importe on sait bien
malheureusement que la majorité des gens
n'y aura pas de le gérer nous en a pas
donné de rendez vous mais après
certaines données sur la caisse rendez
vous mais pas du tout il n'y a pas eu de
rendez vous il a prévu des sorties de me
convaincre et vous avez communiqué sauf
que s'il avait un problème que vient à
chaque fois n'y ait pas eu connaissance
d'un communiqué mercredi que le
gouvernement tiendrait aux comptes je
sais pas vous seriez pas devancé son
gouvernement vous aurez un gouvernement
quel qu'il soit c'est ce qu'il aura été
remaniée attention la porte vous aurez
notamment aux vient peut-être que non
mais la police continue demain nous
allons commencer l'examen du budget de
la sécurité aussi la du social au moment
où nous discutons le budget en cours
d'examen du sommet national et vous
savez très bien que tous les députés de
la majorité ou d'opposition sont en
action et au travail rien ne change pas
la face et ceux ci ceci étant dit
laisser penser que ce remaniement qui
traîne ne cache pas difficulté pour le
gouvernement et le président de la
république je pense que personne ne le
croit personne ne le croit il ya
effectivement une difficulté est qu'on
en soit invoquée l'em2 d'emmanuel macron
alors certes après loin mais si vite si
vite un remaniement d'ampleur puisque
ces 6 is in ses parts dans un
remaniement d'ampleur et se dessine en
général c'est après les élections de mi
mandat
c'est connu de remettre au départ
catastrophe on a connu des remaniements
après des missions payer pour des
raisons politiques
après la cuvée durée d'action etc on a
connu ça
vous devriez vous devriez nous on est
notre invité pourrait poser lui encore
une question jacob le départ d'un
ministre qui pour raisons personnelles
petit personnel décide de quitter
gouvernement il n'y a pas de crise
politique
est ce que vous considérez qu'à une
crise politique et ou est ce parce que
je considère que non je considère que
dans de la même façon qui a pas de crise
politique parce que marie noëlle
lienemann ou emmanuel maurel ont quitté
le parti socialiste je vous rends bien
volontiers enfin il ya une clarification
entre la ligne sociale démocrate et la
ligne qui ne l'étaient pas maintenant la
question c'est que va-t-il rester d'une
ligne sociale-démocrate d'un ps qui
faisait construire en opposition à la
ligne d'emmanuel dacron et ça j'avoue
que je vous souhaite bon courage parce
que je rencontre encore beaucoup de gens
sur le terrain sur le territoire qui
croient au parti socialiste mais qui
croit en une social-démocrate et qui ne
comprennent pas l'opposition
systématique que nous faisons à présent
pauvreté qui était acclamé par les
associations adoubé par les ong par les
acteurs sociaux mais si mais si non mais
si désolé mais si c'est vrai répond dès
lors ce que vous avez vu d'action
sociale qui sont avec interpellations
pour des nuitées sur et qui sont rentrés
sur le terrain et ne comprennent pas
nécessairement la policière d'opposition
j'aimerais tellement pouvoir à dire que
la politique conduite une petite
social-démocrate ça n'est pas le cas y
compris les français ne s'y trompent
plus ils sont à l'immense regret des
français a compris que la politique que
vous meniez tête une chanson l'immense
univers à jean voir quelques-uns sur le
terrain oui j'aurais moi aussi j'en vois
j'envoie des attentats je vois bien ce
qu'ils me disent aujourd'hui y compris
ceux qui ont accompagné ce gouvernement
pendant un an et qui ont espéré et
j'espérais un nouveau michel rocard et
sont tournés sur en réalité un edouard
philippe qui fait lui ce qu'il avait
prévu de faire edouard philippe c'est
certainement le plus cohérent dans ce
gouvernement il avait prévu d'être avec
juppé il fait la politique de juppé ou
de filles ont exactement qu'est ce qui
aurait le seul point le gala fillon le
seul point sur lequel de fait d'accord
avec three lions étaient auparavant
c'est sur la pm avec cécile si je monte
là ce sera quand même oui mais c'est
dommage voilà mais si balancer des trucs
comme ça mais on sur l'agression nous
ferons tout l'été c'est une farine il ya
un an ça devait être celui qui nous a
expliqué que anglais mac elle avait fait
l'honneur de l'europe
un an après il est celui qui refuse
aquarius quand on nous dit qu'il était
l'homme de la planète great games et
nicolas hulot lui-même qui vient de dire
sur un plateau que ce n'est pas possible
que ce n'est pas ce qu'il sait pas ce
qu'il voit new delhi doivent être les
mêmes d'exemplarité nationale ce n'est
pas règlements
par son action vers la violence il ya
quinze jours il est rom libres justes et
sociales et inauguration il est le
président des riches
franchement où elle progresse
on va plus loin sur public sénat du
lundi au jeudi en direct de 18h30 à
19h30 pour l'entretien du jour le match
les idées et le grand débat on reste au
coeur du débat sur public sénat
[Musique]
la matinale d'infos public sénat cette
année c'est le journal des territoires à
7 heures 30 puis à 8 heures après la
macabre territoire d'infos et la vie
politique et on nous sommes toujours
intérieure mais non mais attendez je
vais finir quand olivier est parti à
république en marche il a eu la
délicatesse de me prévenir
il m'a dit voilà ce que moi je pense et
je lui ai dit c'est ce que tu penses tu
peux partir c'est une évidence parce que
y'a pas enfin moi je comprends qu'on
puisse évoluer je comprends qu'on puisse
avoir envie de faire autre chose ce
n'est pas un problème simplement après
une fois qu'olivier est parti à la règle
mais qu'en revanche il à la république
en marche je veux bien qu'on dise à
chaque fois ça exprès mais je ne vous
fais grâce du fait je vous fais grâce du
fait que je ne visite pas edouard
philippe est un républicain il a été
républicain il est passé à république en
marche où il est dans l'orbité de la
république en marche et voilà chacun
ensuite conduit selon sa propre
cohérence sa propre ligne politique
celle de la grue en guerre ethnique en
marche n'est pas la mienne question
alors sur les municipales elles sont
lointains mais on commence à parler à
paris et d'ailleurs comment est ce que
vous le voyez se profiler ces élections
municipales est ce qu'il n'y ait pas d'y
avoir effectivement aucun parc à des
alliances assez assez hétérogène ce qui
pourra effectivement signé un peu plus
le monde une influence des parties petit
grand parti politique du gouvernement
est-ce que les voyelles vous les voyez
se dessiner un psy ou est-ce que vous
pensez que d'ici là la recomposition où
tous les cas la reconstruction du parti
socialiste sera suffisamment avancé pour
que vos élus aujourd'hui qui sont encore
relativement nombreux n'ai pas de
problème j'allais dire existentielles
sur le terrain nous allons au cours des
prochains mois
faire ce que j'imagine tous devraient
faire dire que nous allons à la fois
faire le bilan de ce que nous avons
entrepris en aux collectivités locales
essayez d'en donner une idée assez large
montrer ce qu'est notre spécificité
notre singularité et bâtir une charte
qui engagera celles et ceux qui se
reconnaissent dans nos idées et avancer
sur cette base là ensuite il y aura des
discussions
j'imagine dans toutes les collectivités
pour voir qu'elle sait ce sont celles
qu'elles sont
celles et ceux pardon qui sont prêts sur
ces bases là à nous rejoindre parce que
d'accords ponctuels avec la république
en mars ici ou là aucun accord
d'appareils avec la république en marche
ça je crois que tout le monde l'a
compris il n'y a pas d'accord mais des
questions se posent aux locaux d'ouvrir
pouvait savourer parce que le pardon sur
ma circonscription j'ai pas beaucoup de
communes mais il y à quelques communes
dont les mères sont plutôt de
sensibilité divers droite des communes
sont dans lesquels les maires sont
plutôt socialiste ou une sensibilité
divers gauche et les communes qui sont
en tout cas de mon point de vue très
bien gérée par l'un ou par l'autre et
d'autres communes qui pose des problèmes
aux citoyens moi la première chose que
je vais regarder si on me demande mon
avis c'est quel est le bilan du maire
sortant
quelle est la tante de la population et
quelles sont les forces en présence est
ce qu'elles sont capables de travailler
ensemble autour d'un projet commun c'est
indépendant ce pas ce que dit monsieur
castaner quand il dit qu il faudra une
sous les yeux castaner et en
l'occurrence moi qui l'ait pas créé
encore c'est ce que je pense il sa
dépend de la taille des villes dans les
très grandes villes vous aurez des
listes très politique avec des combats
politiques nationaliser qui se met non
et vous aurez une hymne l'immense
majorité des communes de four lesquels
vous aurez des crises en barrages
regardez dans le nombre de collégiens
d'alger nombre des exécutifs municipaux
dans lesquelles vous avez à la fois des
élus qui ont parrainé emmanuel macron et
d'autres qui ont pu parrainer tel ou tel
autre candidat ne se sont pas déchirés
d'ailleurs on s'attendait à voir
beaucoup moins je pensais qu'ils
auraient beaucoup plus de groupes
d'opposition qui naîtrait au sein d
opposition et majorité qui naîtrait au
sein des majorités
or c'est parce qu'on constate ce qu'on
constate c'est que dans la vraie vie
quand les gens partagent des valeurs
communes
quand ils sont capables de le
reconnaître quand ils ont un projet
commun au service de l'intérêt général
se foutent complètement de l'éthique est
donc en version ils ont envie de
travailler ensemble
ce qu'a dit christophe castaner c'est
que là où ça va ça fera sens on pourra
avoir des accords voir soutenir telle ou
telle candidature
pardon faire beaucoup de pardon de
l'étiquette
ce qui m'intéresse c'est la politique
qui sera menée et la qualité des
personnes nées à croire tout ça
ressemble a quand même un gros goût
ligoule gars quand je vois que
christophe castaner va soutenir
christian estrosi à nice il l'a soutenu
christory oui c'est à dire qu'il va ôter
christian estrosi
il a dit qu'il soutiendrait à nice
christian estrosi qui est on n'a pas dit
qu'ils soutiendraient christian estrosi
il a dit qu'il soutiendrait question
estrosi qu'il m'aimait dans leurs
orbites de la république en marche quand
je vois que ça amène à de telles
contorsions alors qu' il y a quelques
années quand il était candidat aux
régionales contre la même question
estrosi il ya eu tant de mal à se
désister n'a pas dit qui s'ouvre le
viseur estrosi au deuxième tour
actuellement face à marion maréchal-le
pen je me dis que quelque part quelque
chose il n'a jamais dit et fait sauter
de la suite accord ou pas en tous les
cas au niveau local certainement merci
beaucoup monsieur dernière partie de
l'émission maintenant avec donc les deux
ligues faux et oriane mancini qui nous
rejoignent
[Musique]
surprofit oliphant pour vous donner la
réaction d'un internaute sur le site du
figaro qui dit les socialistes sont
cloués dans l'opposition pour l'éternité
alors le démenti dans combien de temps
selon vous écouter il est face à des
gens qui sont très heureux de vrais
socialistes dans une difficulté qu'ils
espèrent indépassable et c'est pas moi
qui les ferait changer d'avis mais
simplement il ya aussi des gens qui
espèrent aujourd'hui une force à gauche
karl d'alterner avec le pouvoir actuel
et mon devoir c'est effectivement de
restaurer cette force là et c'est ce que
cela quoi je m'attèle jour après jour
oriane donc d'une oblique bonsoir arrive
domec
olivier faur vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure les élections européennes
or si l'on compte bien il pourrait y
avoir trois quatre cinq listes de gauche
est ce que ce n'est pas faire un
formidable cadeau à la république en
marche à emmanuel macron est peut-être
encore plus ce rassemblement national et
à marine le pen
est-ce que des discussions des accords
sont encore possibles au sein de la
gauche pour ces élections
vous avez raison c'est une formidable
opportunité pour que emmanuel macron au
soir du scrutin
prétendant avoir une victoire là où en
réalité il aura enregistré une défaite
parce que nous avons peut-être à nouveau
après avoir eu pendant longtemps la
droite la plus bête du monde la gauche
la plus bête du monde avec cette
incapacité à trouver un accord alors que
sur l'essentiel
effectivement nous pouvons nous mettre
d'accord entre les réformistes les
écologistes celles et ceux qui veulent
modifier le cours de l'europe mais qui
sont effectivement trop européen et donc
je finis juste pour répondre aux actions
ennemies de faux pour vous dire que j'ai
dit depuis le début
enfin porte était ouverte que je
n'allais pas courir après les uns et les
autres
s'il n'avait pas la volonté mais que si
cette volonté là existent ma main est
tendue
je souhaite effectivement que nous
puissions parvenir si cela est possible
si les enjeux d'appareils si les
égoïsmes d'appareils si les patriotisme
d'appareils ne sont pas plus puissant
que l'intérêt général et bien moi je
souhaite effectivement que nous
puissions nous retrouver
parce que dans un scrutin où on voit que
la république en marche aujourd'hui tu
en train de dévisser il était quasiment
à 30
ils sont aujourd'hui à vin peut être en
dessous de 20 une liste qui permettrait
de retrouver ensemble ces forces
pourraient la tangente et et donnerait
une autre allure à ce quinquennat et
permettrait de retrouver une force que
nous avons collectivement perdu et qui
donne effectivement par défaut une
capacité emmanuel macron cette
discussion on voit bien qu'elle est
aujourd'hui difficile voire impossible
avec jean luc mélenchon est ce qu'elles
existent avec benoît - est-ce qu'elles
existent avec les rivières domaine il ya
un écart sur la question européenne nous
ne pouvons pas être d'accord avec jean
luc mélenchon dont sur d'autres sujets
il ya des combats communs que nous
pouvons mener ensemble mais sur la
question européenne
cette impossible je vois même que sur la
question migratoire
il ya des sujets sur lesquels ce serait
très difficile de se mettre d'accord
parce que pour moi il n'est pas question
de laisser naître l'idée que nous
pourrions nous décomplexer par rapport à
la knesset des réfugiés du droit d'asile
vous pensez que c'est l'attitude de jean
luc mélenchon aujourd'hui je trouve que
dans son mouvement il ya aujourd'hui une
ambiguïté qui n'existait pas jusqu'alors
et qu'elle met d'être levés et que ça
suppose maintenant à lui de dire et
points moi je ne prête pas je reconnais
jean luc mélenchon je ne veux pas
laisser entendre ici que il aurait une
pensée qui puisse être raciste mais il y
a quand même cette tentation qu'on voit
bien chez les allemands de die linke
avec à auch ten avec le mouvement de
madame wagen knecht 1 qui aujourd'hui
cherchent à jouer avec ce un sentiment
qu'elle croit être un sentiment
populaire et qui est un sentiment qui
peut être aux limites de la xénophobie
mais il ya donc un manque d'insécurité
culturel comme on dit ça et on ne peut
pas le nier non plus dans les
populations les voie moi je n'en voyais
rien mmm aviaire je ne veux gagner en
bavière
contrairement à ce que tout le monde
pensait là et a fait 11 % et non pas 19
ou 20 donc ça prouve aussi ils peuvent
être contenues par les verts et les
sociaux démocrates
c'est vrai mais maison que c'est ce ce
climat d'insécurité quelques rêves
il existe aussi en france mais ça
suppose
ayant nous mêmes un discours clair sur
la façon dont nous souhaitons accueillir
et moi je souhaite être le plus clair
possible quand nous accueillons demain
aujourd'hui et demain un réfugié de
droit d'asile ne sais pas pour qu'ils
viennent imposer ici
ce qu'est son mode de vie qu'il impose à
la société française dans son ensemble
et donc il ya des règles qui sont
impératives les règles de la laïcité les
règles de l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes elles ne sont pas négociables
mais cela suppose être rappelé mais ça
suppose aussi d'accueillir et de faire
ce geste minimal qui suit la solidarité
parce que les valeurs européennes
c'est aussi ça revient sur cette
question des européennes le
rassemblement de la gauche vous seriez
prêt ce qui n'est pas de têtes de listes
socialistes aux européennes et que la
gauche se rassemble sous une autre
manière écoutez on n'en est pas là mais
la porte est ouverte à une discussion et
je souhaite que nous puissions si c'est
possible nous retrouver et faire en
sorte que demain il y a une tête de
liste sur laquelle on puisse nous
accorder si c'est possible mais je ne
veux pas à ce stade dire quoi que ce
soit je dis simplement que si on peut
s'accorder consacrera et moi je ne
souhaite pas d'entrée de jeu schaaf
admettre des préalables ou mettre des
conditions aussi s'agit simplement que
pour l'instant et j'ai le sentiment que
je n'entends pas d'écho à cette
proposition alors que ma main est tendue
depuis longtemps on va parler du bric
site 1 semaine spéciale pour leur
excellent puisque aurélien sommet
européen mercredi et jeudi les
négociations butent toujours notamment
sur le sort de la frontière irlandaise
pour vous lasse l'absence d'accord vous
semble désormais inéluctable
c'est un risque mais je souhaite que
nous puissions aller jusqu'au bout et
puissions faire comprendre aux patients
en entendu mais enfin vous avez perdu
votre micro voilà donc je souhaite que
nous puissions aller au bout de cette
affaire est que nous puissions à la fois
respecter le vote et annick et que nous
puissions aussi faire en sorte que nous
puissions maintenant travailler à 27
puisque l'augmenter et le sortir et que
nous puissions montrer aussi que nous
allons faire enfin que ça c'est un coup
de pied de l'europe parce que l'europe
ce n'est pas simplement
j'ai à dire une auberge espagnole
l'exemple est mal choisi mais on ne peut
pas venir l'épuiser et puis après en
repartir etc il faut permettre à chacun
de comprendre ce qu'elle apporte au site
sans accord c'est des conséquences sur
la france est ce que pour vous la france
est prête à 1 m'excite sans accord
écoutez je ne suis pas au gouvernement
aujourd'hui et je n'ai pas faire
semblant d'avoir tous les éléments d'un
accord tout cas ça ne me connaît mais ce
que je crois c'est que healy a
aujourd'hui une situation dans laquelle
il faut sortir de laquelle il faut
sortir le plus vite possible pour
permettre à chacun de retrouver une
forme de clarté avec on parlait tout à
l'heure de la difficulté pour les gauche
française a discuté ensemble et à
s'allier en espagne le gouvernement
socialiste de pedro sanchez s'est
accordé avec la gauche radicale de
podemos sur le budget 2010 9
pourquoi est-ce que ce qui est possible
en espagne ne l'est pas en france la
faute à qui vous savez que cette fois ci
effectivement personne chaise est devenu
premier ministre à la suite d'une motion
de censure constructive comme on dit en
espagne et que c'est la suite de quoi il
ya eu une nouvelle façon un soutien sans
participation de podemos à ce
gouvernement
mais ça n'est pas venu tout seul et ça
n'est pas venu tout de suite
vous vous souvenez qu'il y a quelques
mois à peine la même question avait été
posée à podemos dans un premier temps il
avait refusé de s'effacer devant le psoe
le parti socialiste espagnol parti
socialiste ouvrier espagnol et donc il a
fallu du temps pour que les esprits
finalement bouge et finalement pour le
meilleur puisque aujourd'hui on a une
gauche espagnol qui se porte bien et qui
est à nouveau un synonyme d'espérance
pour ce peuple là donc ça me laisse de
l'espoir pour la csn en espagne aussi
avait une lutte pour l'hégémonie à
gauche aujourd'hui ils ont enterré la
haine je ne n'y a pas de lutte pour
l'hégémonie ça je crois que
effectivement nous devons enfin notre
deuil pendant trop longtemps nous avons
pensé que nous étions hégémonique à
gauche et que nous traitions nos
partenaires comme des supplétifs ces
périodes là elle est terminée
et donc moi je fête des partenaires mais
je crois aussi que effectivement il y a
c'est ainsi un grand parti central à
gauche qui est le parti socialiste est
que si nous ne sommes pas en capacité de
retrouver être la force principale à
gauche
alors là non c'est impossible parce que
nous sommes les seuls à pouvoir faire le
pont entre ceux qui viennent au centre
gauche et ceux qui viennent de la gauche
de la gauche
ce fut l'oeuvre de mitterrand ce fut
l'oeuvre de jospin qui d'ailleurs en son
temps avait dans son gouvernement un
certain jean luc mélenchon vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure la question des
migrations qui sera peut-être l'un des
sujets sains des élections européennes
est-ce qu'il faut que la france accorde
un pavillon français à l'aquarius ce
navire humanitaire qui va repêcher des
réfugiés et des migrants dans la
méditerranée oui je plaide pour cela je
plaide pour que la france au moins
symboliquement puisse donner son accord
pour que le pavillon de la curieuse soit
français ce serait une belle image est
un beau symbole et pour que ce bateau
puisse continuer sauver des vies parce
qu'aujourd'hui il est immobilisé et donc
c'est quand même un comble de voir ce
président qui prétend être un
progressiste qui résonnait il ya un an
et demi que malgré ma qu'elle avait été
l'aude noir de l'europe en accueillant
un million de réfugiés sur son sol
national
et voilà que maintenant pour un bateau
qui transporte entre 50 et 150 réfugiés
à chaque fois eh bien vous êtes
incapable de faire ce geste minimal 7,1
des sens vous avez cité à l'instant la
des figures tutélaires du parti
socialiste certaines évidemment ne sont
plus là mais ce que tous les gens que
vous avez invité les anciens premiers
secrétaires les premiers ministres
seront là pour l'inauguration de votre
nouveau siège en banlieue parisienne à
ivry-sur-seine ce sera le mois prochain
ce sera le mois prochain ils seront en
chantier paraît
je suis l'héritier d'une histoire qui
n'a pas commencé avec moi et qui ne se
terminera pas avec moi non plus et donc
effectivement ils seront invités
et après ils bradent vrai ou pas
d'accord on à paris alors on a parlé de
marie noëlle lienemann
il y a quand même une vague de
protestation qui enfle vous l'avez lancé
ce week-end et notamment du côté des
sénateurs
peut-elle rester sénatrice socialiste
peut-elle rester vice présidente du
sénat maintenant qu'elle a claqué la
porte du ps quel est votre avis que
demander si elle ne veut plus l'être oui
que elle pourrait difficilement être
sénatrice socialiste ce que j'ai
simplement rappelé moi je ne vais pas
courir après marie noëlle lienemann
julie simplement je lui rappelle qu'elle
veut elle vous doit son nom aux partis
son mandat mais elle a été élue après
l'élection présidentielle sur une liste
sénatoriale dont elle n'ignore rien de
la ligne du parti socialiste elle
ignorer yens ses colistiers ignoré une
ligne aérienne du groupe parlementaire
auquel adhérait elle s'en va moi je dis
simplement que quand on a là une logique
et une magic de conviction qu'on veut
affirmer et qu'on veut ce afficher une
pureté que les autres n'auraient pas ça
suppose aller jusqu'au bout de son jason
est donc dans la logique serait de dire
puisque en fait je ne me reconnais plus
dans ce parti je vais jusqu'au bout et
je rends ce mandat que je considère
comme étant un acquis avec parti
socialiste sur la décence mais je dis
simplement que quand on a une logique de
conviction on va jusqu'au bout de ses
convictions et que pour l'instant j'ai
le sentiment que l est à mi-chemin ce
qu'elle a reproché à d'autres autrefois
quand il partait chez emmanuel macron ou
ailleurs et bien elle a qu'a aujourd'hui
se l'appliquer à elle même et donc moi
je souhaite que l face comme elle comme
bon lui semblera un avion suis pas là et
je ne rappelle jamais je n'ai pas votre
position clairement voulait d'abord en
quoi
non mais ma position elle est partie
c'est pas je ne vais pas la retenir par
du sénat qu elle est partie du groupe
socialiste du sénat est elle partie du
parti socialiste
donc les choses sont claires maintenant
il ya quelque chose que nous ne pouvons
pas faire c'est l'enlever son mandat sur
qu'elle détient à vous dites c'est la
logique me jean veil en l'honnêteté ou
la décence l'honnêteté à la logique à
d'essence si vous voulez en tout cas je
vois bien que le parti socialiste a
servi à beaucoup mais que en retour ces
gens là ne sont pas jusqu'au bout dans
le service qu'il pourrait rendre à la
vie politique comment peut-on comprendre
que des gens qui les tiennent leur
mandat par un parti politique finalement
le conserve pour un autre parti
politique alors c'est que demain
clairement voulu demander de
démissionner par conséquent de rendre sa
vice-présidence puisqu'elle est
vice-présidente au nom du parti
socialiste est exactement l excédent au
nom du parti socialiste la décence
voudrait qu'elles le fassent meilleur je
dis simplement pourquoi cette question
là vient maintenant parce que elle n'a
pas affiché simplement un départ elle
nous explique qu'elle est en train de
faire une scission donc est vraiment en
train de chercher à donner une dimension
politique
c'est à ce départ d'autres sont partis
avant elle dans le constat l'assemblée
récemment et à l'assemblée je pense à
gérer jso nico qui est un collègue
il nous a dit moi je souhaite rejoindre
benoît hamon et en même temps je les
souhaite rester au groupe nous avons
voté à l'unanimité
nous avons accepté son maintien mais il
n'avait pas là dans la volonté dans
l'ambition de dire qu'il y avait une
déchirure au sein du ps et qu'il était
en fait des accords complexes qui se
passait nous a dit je suis plus à l'aise
avec benoît hamon mais je reste avec
vous parce que vous êtes mon groupe et
ma famille politique on a répondu on est
en rupture alors est-ce que vous allez
être aussi clair concernant une autre
personnalité monsieur pavageau le patron
de fo qui est englué dans le scandale
des fichiers là où on avait
manifestement trouver des noms peu
flatteur un grand nombre de responsables
du syndicat est ce que vous demandez est
ce que vous estimez que la logique là la
décence
l'honnêteté serait qu'il parte qu'il
cède son fauteuil de patron de fo parce
que ça fait beaucoup de tort d'abord à
sion syndicats mais à tout le
syndicalisme peut-être oui et votre avis
alors mon avis enfin il est n'est pas un
avis éclairé je voudrais d'abord avant
que de se lancer définitivement sur le
sort de monsieur pavage ou qu'ils nous
disent qu'ils avaient connaissance de ce
fichier si c'était une commande de sa
part je ne veux pas l'accuser trop vite
il a dit que c'était une belle connerie
donc oui s'assurer que c'est plus qu'une
connerie c'est une faute
ficher les gens et donner le sentiment
qu'on peut y compris sur l'orientation
politique sexuelle qu'on puisse les
qualifiés y compris j'ai cru comprendre
que on atteint et mmhg dans
l'intelligence bon ça c'est
insupportable inadmissible
donc même impossible si les faits sont
ce là si monsieur pavageau on avait la
connaissance c'était une croix ne savent
pas il doit effectivement en tirer
toutes les conséquences partir donc
voilà ollier fort depuis quelques jours
la taxe d'habitation arrivent dans les
boîtes à lettres pour une fois ça
devrait être une bonne nouvelle pour 80%
des français qui devrait bénéficier de
la baisse d'un tiers de cette taxe
d'habitation promise par emmanuel macron
mais environ 6000 communes ont décidé
d'augmenter le taux local de cette taxe
d'habitation est ce que vous comprenez
cette décision d'un certain nombre de
maires alors que le gouvernement a
promis de compenser à l'euro près
d'abord rien chose c'est que vous dites
il a 80 % des français pour qui il y
aura une baisse mais il n'y a pas qu'à
60 des français qui payent d'acceptation
réalisation à l'heure où on se parle
80% des français qui l'appellent
effective oui c'est qu'il est pas la
même chose c'est important de français
qui ne la paye pas et qui eux ne verront
rien ne sont pas compensés images les
noms mais imagine ce retraité qui l'an
passé avec la csg s'est vu fonctionner
1.8 cette année qui voit que sa passion
n'est plus indexée sur l'inflation et on
lui dit mais vous inquiétez pas bien
toute l'acceptation d'abaisser mais il a
payé pas car il fait comment le mythe
parce que c'est ce que nous disent les
chiffres qu'ils ont données partout
d'instituts c'est que pour la première
fois on a une baisse de poids d'achat
pour les 1% de français les plus pauvres
c'est ça la réalité
et vous aurez une augmentation de 1
petit pourcent pour la classe moyenne
qui va bénéficier de cela avant même de
se voir retirer sa tante de financement
parle de veegaete texte de taxes
indirectes et vous avez les plus riches
qui eux voient alors pouvoir d'achat
augmenter de 17 18%
c'est ça la réalité du maquereau nisme
c'est que en fait vous avez du
cosmétique pour le milieu des français
pour la classe moyenne le lâchage de
ceux qui effectivement ne sont pas le
bon terrain électoral pour lui et une
clientèle électorale qui favorise
amplement et qui est celle des prix mais
justement cette baisse de la taxe
d'habitation pour les ménages qui la
paye ça concerne peu ou pour les classes
moyennes
or avec cette décision d'un certain
nombre de maires 7 cette baisse va être
rogné
est ce que est ce que vous le regrettez
mais moi je ne sais pas je ne sais pas
quelles sont ces mères je ne connais pas
leur les raisons qui peuvent les motiver
je suis simplement que je vois qu'il ya
une campagne absurde c'est un des traits
de monnaies par la public en marche sur
le mode balances ton maire pour laisser
pantois
comment peut-on arriver à comparer
aujourd'hui des mères à des chocs
c'est absurde et c'est un procédé qui me
choque qui me heurte le parce qu'on ne
peut pas comparer aujourd'hui un maire
qui fait face à des difficultés dans sa
commune à quelqu'un qui a commis des
crimes ou qui sait a laissé aller au
harcèlement sexuel franchement mais il
faut quand même qu'ils retrouvent le
sens des réalités
c'est pas possible d'être sur ce terrain
là et et d'agiter pardon de le dire mais
tout à l'heure un aïoli et veyran qui
nous disait qu'il fallait se battre
contre le populisme typiquement ce
procédé la tête merci
populis et tergnier françois hollande a
dit qu'il le regrettait d'avoir annoncé
une présidence normale il aurait dû dire
humaines sociales a précisé
c'est le début d'une mairie culpa ou
est-ce que soit changé la tournure du
quinquennat pour ne pas dire une
présidence normale pour vous d'un mot je
ne sais pas si ce serait faire grand
chose à la tournée du quinquennat et ce
n'est pas les appellations qui font qui
change grand chose au jugement que l'on
fait mais je préfère aussi le mot
humains au mot normal qui ne correspond
pas à ce que la présidente qui n'est
jamais normal merci à l'effort merci
devraient être avec nous aujourd'hui
merci à tous les deux bonsoir à tous
nous nous retrouvons donc la semaine
prochaine pour audition publique
[Musique]
non